The joe rogan experience and draping topical CBD oil,
which is a really good,
yes,
yes.
CBD is illegal across the board.
Okay.
Non Non psychoactive,
but the FDA is trying to stop that.
Of course.
Follow the money.
Yeah,
it was creeps.
It's a good explanation for just about everything.
Yeah.
They're trying to put it in the same classification as heroin.
It's hilarious.
Yeah.
So stupid.
It's just 100% pharmaceutical drug companies.
Institutions of decision making.
Yup.
Well it's just creepy.
People with money that don't want to lose money to CBD oil because it's so much
better for you and healthy and natural and does the exact same passion.
How much the drug companies would lose or gain if they started selling.
It fucks just,
they want to monopolize it.
That's the problem.
They want patents.
They want to be able to patent things.
You know?
That's,
but that's a,
like we were talking about before about the things that are in the Amazon.
I mean it stayed there so many different plants that can deal with so many
different ailments that people have.
But I,
Alaska,
yeah,
that's one of them.
Sure.
Have you done it?
I haven't,
but it's kind of interesting.
Yeah.
Have you done any psychedelics?
No.
Never done drugs ever?
No drugs,
no pot ever?
Never.
Oh,
you scared?
No.
I just,
my dad's scared the living daylights out of me when I was a kid and he told me
that if I ever,
he's like,
you get tested for drugs and you fail,
you,
you won't ever be a race car driver.
You told me that about drinking and driving too.
If you get,
if you lose your license,
you won't be able to race.
And then,
you know,
what are you going to be when you grow up then?
You know,
he threatened me with Oh dad.
Remedial remedial jobs and um,
yeah,
so he'd scared the living daylights out of me.
Truth be told you can lose your license still race.
Also,
truth be told,
I didn't get drug tested until way later,
but we do get drug tests.
You're running a drug farm.
Oh,
well one you're wanting a drug farm.
Well,
kind of I guess a drug farm lady.
It's legal buck 20 a hundred percent drug farm.
It's wonderful,
delicious taste in drugs.
It sure is.
Yes.
That's fucked up on wine.
Yeah.
And what does that,
that's true.
And addicted to drinking alcoholism.
I mean there's a lot of other things that you can do that I know altering that
aren't addictive.
Right?
You're running a plant based drug farm.
100% cash crops.
Yeah.
So are you doing,
you're a drug dealer.
Well let's just go all the way.
Well,
if I was going to do something,
what would be the first thing I would do?
Pot.
Oh,
for sure.
Okay.
Nice and light.
Real slow.
Don't take much.
What does that mean?
It just take a little bit.
You don't want to freak out.
Like the,
one of the major problems that people have when they first start smoking pot,
they'll take like two or three heads and he can take one one like that's it.
Put it down,
right Jamie.
Yeah.
Jamie will tell you,
okay,
we'll hit walkaway.
Yeah,
don't fuck with edibles.
Leave those alone.
Those,
those you need to build up to those things.
Those are,
those are completely different experience.
I experienced users.
Well,
it's not just that even experienced users,
they don't recognize the fact that it's a completely different psychoactive.
Yeah,
yeah.
When THC,
THC,
no,
when it's processed by your liver produces 11 hydroxy metabolite,
which is four to five times more psychoactive than THC.
It's way more potent.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Which is why people far reach out when they eat edibles and they just don't,
don't eat the whole Brownie.
No.
She's a couple crumbs and then don't even think about having any more for at
least two hours.
Let it settle in.
Let it,
yeah.
Give yourself time.
Don't freak out if for 15,
20 minutes and be like,
it's not working.
Right.
Don't do that.
Sometimes when I'm drinking,
I'm like,
I'm sure man,
this is my third drank.
It just doesn't seem to be working.
And then I hit it harder and then,
um,
I don't remember anything.
Brownout or blackout or drugs or do drugs.
Yeah.
Actually,
one of the,
one of the first times I heard one of your podcasts,
I think it was,
it was about DMT.
Yeah.
That's the motherlode DMT is the psychoactive ingredient that's in Io Osca.
Right,
right.
The most potent.
That seems like a cleaner,
cleaner way to do it as opposed to Iowasca where are you?
Yeah.
Throw up and shake yourself.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You,
it's definitely probably,
uh,
it's also quicker,
you know,
like the worst,
the longest it's going to take a sec,
15 or 20 minutes,
but there's some places that are doing it now with they're doing it
intravenously.
So those trips are apparently,
that was how they did it in,
um,
there's a book called Dmt,
the spirit molecule molecule by this guy,
Doctor Rick Strassman who did all these studies out of the University of New
Mexico.
And uh,
they were the first FDA approved clinical studies.
Um,
but it was a group of people.
Yeah.
Awesome.
It's amazing.
It was amazing.
But they didn't intervene the intravenously yeah.
And they were gone.
So for like 40 minutes,
like pull them off into the,
off into the other dimension.
I was going to say,
so other dimension,
right?
This dream state is,
what do you think is like a dream state?
Uh,
it's very similar because they believe that your brain during heavy rem sleep
also produces DMT.
And they think that's okay because we all have it.
Everybody has it.
Yeah.
Everybody has recurring and everyone,
yes.
It's produced by your liver,
your lungs,
and now they know it's also produced at least in rats,
by your pineal gland,
which is literally your third eye.
It's it actually in certain reptiles,
it actually has a retina and the Lens.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it is.
It is an eye.
I'm always trying to decalcify my Pineo Glenn,
is that real?
I don't know.
You get that from them crystal people in Sedona.
Yeah.
They say it's like fluoride.
Fluoride is calcifying your pineal gland,
man.
Like,
okay,
cool.
Getting in there.
Yeah.
Getting through my mouth and I said,
are you sure?
Are you sure Florence?
Because everything you are what you eat sordo but are you what you drink wine?
Yes.
I get better with age.
Duh.
Yeah.
I don't know if you've really,
your pineal gland actually gets calcified by fluoride in drinking water.
I didn't.
That sounds like some hippie horseshit.
It does sound hippie horse shit.
I'd like to see some scientific proof,
but hey man,
with all the hippy shit,
there's not a lot of scientific proof with it.
No,
no.
There's not the sense of knowing.
That's what it comes down to is a sense of knowing,
like,
do you really feel like this is making sense to you?
Does it register?
And you're like,
I don't know why I believe this,
but I just do.
I don't even know where it came from.
[inaudible].